in case you didn't know we don't live in
a world full of unicorns rainbows and
cupcakes the real world isn't a utopia
we don't like everything in fact there's
a whole lot to seriously dislike yet for
the last seven years in Facebook's world
all we've been able to do is like
everything but today that changes
instead of adding a dislike button
Facebook is adding five new reaction
buttons when you hover now over the like
button you'll see five new options love
haha Wow sad and angry on your phone
just long press the like button and
they'll pop up it seemed dead simple
right wrong after using these for a week
I've discovered that these emotions are
more complicated than you think
here are my rules on when to use them
and when not to rule number one The
Beatles were wrong all you need isn't
love please don't be that person that
loves everything come on do you really
love that new McDonald's pancake and
chicken sandwich as much as your new
baby niece
okay perhaps you shouldn't answer that
but there's real harmony over using love
just like there's real harm in overusing
the word in real life so I went to the
experts to get some guidance love is
something that we're committed to that
we're passionate about and if we don't
make that distinction then maybe in two
years Facebook is going to have to come
out with another set of buttons one of
which would be no this is something that
I really really truly love rule - don't
let the sad and angry buttons replace
real expression for the first time we
have the ability to express anger and
sadness with just a quick of a button
but that doesn't mean we should when
someone posts sad news don't use the
button to get out of expressing deeper
more meaningful sentiment in a comment
rule 3 be aware of the ways hah-ha can
be interpreted take this example your
friends dog just had surgery and post a
photo of payment a cone responding with
haha may seem funny to you your of
course commenting that the dog looks
like a satellite dish
but to her haha he just had surgery the
biggest rule of them all don't take
these too personally and end up like
this only one love remember at the end
of the day these are just cartoons
masquerading as human emotions we'll see
about that